you know apparently in the United States
of America people who work quote-unquote
regular jobs are something to be shamed
especially when you have come from being
a star even if it's only a relative star
to finding yourself having to work at a
grocery store this is what happened with
Jeffery Owens former star of the hit TV
series The Cosby Show now I mean you
have to put this in perspective The
Cosby Show was back in the 80s I was a
little boy when The Cosby Show came on
Alvin Thibodeau was the character on
that show and that show ended somewhere
in the 90s so I mean people I guess
people have in their mind this
expectation that you make enough money
as a move as a TV star as a secondary
actor on the TV show that it wouldn't
warrant you needing to get a regular job
well apparently and we'll pull up the
image on the screen what you see on your
screen now is an image of Jeffery Owens
working at Trader Joe's and he looks
like a guy just he looks like a regular
guy going through regular life I mean
this is if you catch any of us on a
regular day this is how we look and this
is how we go through these periods in
our life where we have to get a job I
mean when has it ever been an issue for
someone to have a job well apparently
Fox News thought this was newsworthy and
the Daily Mail which is a rag of a
magazine of a website rather which we
could say the same thing about Fox News
they promoted this story and it went
viral and so many people had a lot to
say about it but most specifically the
actor himself got wind of it and he felt
the embarrassment because of it I want
to play a clip from Jeffery Owens Alvin
Thibodeau from the Cosby Show on Good
Morning America just this morning I mean
I was I was really devastated but it
lasted it was the period of devastation
was so short because so shortly after
that the response is my wife and I
started to read these responses from
like literally all over the world of
support and
so fortunately the shame part didn't
last very long it hurt but then it's
just it's it's amazing I mean there is
he said that said that he was devastated
because of this and it was only because
of the outpouring of love from everybody
else that he was able to not stay
devastated but listen to this quote from
the Daily Mail this is what they thought
was newsworthy they said quote the actor
who played Elvan in the show The Cosby
Show is now working at it as a cashier
at Trader Joe's photos revealed a
shopper spotted Jeffery Owens who was 57
behind a till at the store in Clifton
New Jersey where staff earned around $11
an hour see the problem here is that the
only way this is news is if you think
there is something wrong with the person
who was once on television having to
work a quote-unquote regular job like
the rest of us Joe schmo's you know
that's the only way that this is news
and because that's the only way this is
news this is your attempt to generate
cliques based on shaming somebody for
earning a quote/unquote earnest a honest
day's living now you know the socialist
side of me says that this guy nobody in
the country who's 60 years old basically
should have to work 910 hours a day
making $11 an hour just so that they can
live but I'll set that aside for the
David Pakman show and I'll just talk
about the the regular conversation about
when is it ever a bad thing for people
to earn an honest living and you know it
just speaks to the lack of integrity in
media outlets particularly Fox News
which is not shocking but it has to be
pointed out they are willing to defame
anybody and betray their own ideas and
notions of a quote/unquote honest day's
work they're forever telling people oh
just go out and get a job you need to do
this you need to do that and here's
someone doing that exact thing and Fox
News chooses it chooses to use this as
an opportunity to shame him and get
clicks off of it because of it
the story itself
may have a good ending Tyler Perry who
for those of you who don't know Tyler
Perry he's the director writer and actor
behind the Medea series I am NOT a huge
fan but that's neither here nor there I
really appreciate what he did this
morning he tweeted on Twitter he said
quote Jeffrey Owens I'm about to start
shooting owns number one drama next week
come join us I have so much respect for
people who hustle between gigs the
measure of a true artist and I mean so
good on Tyler Perry for doing that man
that is that is a huge thing and I hope
that this works out good for Jeffrey
Owens I hope that this sets him up for
the rest of his life so he doesn't have
to be working on his feet at 60 years
old earning any amount of money he could
just sit back and live on the money that
he's getting ready to make with with
Tyler Perry but for the rest of us I
mean all of us are in this kind of
situation from time to time all of us
have to go and get jobs in between
trying to work our big ideas of trying
to work our hustle and and what whatever
the case may be and and this should just
lets you know that in this terms of
elitism that that that that snobby
elitism that FoxNews tries to divide all
the time in leftist we get it directly
from them on a national level trying to
shame somebody who is making a
quote/unquote honest day's living I want
to share one more example of the media
trying to shame an actor a former actor
this is a clip from TMZ back from 2011
when they caught the former actor from
the from the hit show that I still love
martin working selling used cars so
what's he up to now
movies Broadway infomercials he is now
working as a car salesman No
[Music]
from acting on Martin to selling cars
man tell us how is that going it's going
wonderful it's wrong wonderful he said
it started out to research a role you
know and then I just kind of kept doing
it there's no shame in taking care of
your family so you know I mean all these
all these people I know this is David's
program and you know it's prop it's
broadcast on radio so I'm going to limit
my profanity but all these people you
know shaming folks like this you know
yeah just you go to hell man because the
reality of it is is that this is the
existence this is how most Americans
live period period most Americans live
where they're having to work make ends
meet living paycheck-to-paycheck
just so that they can support their
families I mean more people than you
realize a lot of people don't like to
talk about living paycheck to paycheck
they don't wanna have to talk about
living in poverty because they're
ashamed of it because the society does
exactly this if you're not rich if
you're not successful then they look
down on you in reality the majority of
us are not rich we're not successful
we're just out here hustling like these
two guys who were shamed by media